We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p I've
talked about activism that works many times
on the show.
And today's color brings up a really good
question about exactly this issue.
Take a listen.
Hey David, I have a question.
Why isn't America saying to hell with this
current regime that's in the White House?
Why are we merchant through the streets in
Washington?
And the reasons why have we just gotten used
to the abuses of human rights at this current
regime has enforced or I don't know, it's
just, it's messed up, man.
People should be marching through the streets
of Washington saying to hell with this.
And you know, having like a Hong Kong type
motivation of protest.
That's right.
And
the reason why people aren't is a feature
of the system, not a bug.
I've talked about this before.
Uh, if people need to work multiple jobs in
order to make ends meet, if people are working,
um, in hourly positions with a limited time
off and the inability to take a day off and
go protest.
If people just can't afford to take a bus
or drive into the nearest urban area, we're
one of these mass gatherings in order to protest
are taking place, they're not going to be
able to do it.
They're not going to do it.
And this is exactly why we have a self perpetuating
vicious cycle in our economy.
Wages are stagnant, inequality goes up.
The average person increasingly is held hostage
by wages that haven't gone up and mediocre
or terrible health insurance that they still
absolutely need to continue getting through
their employers.
So what does that mean?
That they don't have the wherewithal, the
resources, or the ability, uh, or the free
time to actually go and become activists in
order to change that same system that prevents
them from going and becoming active as it's
a circle?
Okay.
I've talked about this so many times and the
is absolutely right.
Have we become accustomed to this new era
of scandal?
No longer being scandal.
Yes, a little bit.
We have it happens to all of us.
I talked about it last week.
A of outrageous stuff has become normal in
a sense or we have an a in a way become sort
of numb to it because it's exhausting for
everything to be a scandal every single day.
So things that should be scandals aren't because
they're scandals every day.
But the other effect of this is that it actually
the very system that so desperately needs
to be changed is part of what prevents us
from actually going out and becoming activists
to change the system.
And the corporations love that.
And the uh, sources of power that maintain
the status quo.
Love that.
That is a feature of the system.
And unless we change that, if, unless we break
that cycle one way or another, now unfortunately
nothing is going to change.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Beta or re-org revealing
that he and his wife are descended from slave
owners.
We will talk about Amazon workers protesting
prime day, and we will also talk about the
Puerto Rican governor defined calls to resign
over some text chat scandals that have arisen.
All of those stories and more on the David
Pakman show.
Bonus show, two ways to get access to do it.
Become a member@wwwdotjoinpacmandotcombecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slack David Pakman show.
I'll speak to you then